what's a sunset kind of the Beeb's is
officially a hunt ik talk and he's got
one word for you
yummy yeah you got that that's Justin's
new song yummy so it's fitting that his
first three tic tacs were all him lips
and game to it yummy is Justin's first
solo release in over four years
and it's got a whole lot of steamy
references to wife Haley like this one
he's also making it clear that his wife
is his number one of course we also get
a reference to Drew house as well aka
justin's street where lines jew house
slippers on with a smile on my face
[Music]
you got me
and obviously Haley is a big fan of the
song that she posted about it on her
Instagram story and here wrote quote aa
swipe up to listen I love it
this all comes just days after Justin
released the trailer for his new YouTube
docu-series seasons you want to start by
talking about the last four years Wow
as humans we go through so many ups and
downs so many good seasons bad seasons
you know sometimes we want to give up
he and his loved ones get candid about
what the singers gone through over the
past few years he's taking a very long
break and in that time he's found his
wife he's grown a lot and he's ready to
express himself through music again
performing is the thing that he loves
most in this world
for him to say that he didn't want to do
it I was concerned he was a show of
himself
no one's ever grown up in the history of
humanity like Justin Bieber Haley is of
course also part of the documentary
there's a lot of pressure that I think
people don't see
they're so cute Justin also teases his
upcoming album a little bit
I can never remake this um it's gotta be
perfect
Oh weird
I'm excited just nervous a little bit
this album is different because of where
I'm at in my life
Wow I don't know about you but I for one
am so excited for Justin's new album the
new documentary and of course more
tick-tocks kind of yeah you got that
yeah so good for all the latest on
Justin at stick with all things et until
next time I'm Katie Krauss and bye for
now
[Music]